The global society in the landscape of
our,
of our global community is really
changing rapidly and there are trends
that are developing that I think it
embraced and accelerated could have a
profound positive effect on the
trajectory of our global society.
And I think the open source movement and
data sharing I think is a very,
very big part of that.
It's important for organizations to have
all the pieces of the puzzle,
especially if these are development
organizations,
these are crisis response organizations.
Um,
but we have not to date really had a
sufficient effective means to share
data.
And I don't buy that.
I don't mean we have technical barriers
to sharing data.
We have cultural barriers to sharing
data.
Uh,
there are a lot of organizations around
the world including crisis response and
development and humanitarian
organizations that are reluctant to
share the real data that makes that,
that and enables true collaboration.
And I think that's a mindset we need to,
to get around.
The other thing is there's a difference
between providing data and providing
data in a usable user friendly way that
people could actually use for good.
And so there are a lot of efforts around
the world to be able to take a
particularly big data and to put that
into bite size bits to put that in
something that's,
that can be used by the public used by
citizen scientists used by governments
to create good.
And I think there's a,
there's a strong movement in that
direction but we've got a long way to
go.
One of the things that I think is really
going to affect our globe society is a,
and one of the things that I think is
going to propel open source and
transparency and data sharing is I
believe that true open collaboration
which requires all those things is going
to be a tremendous economic engine.
And I think that those organizations and
those people and those governments that
deal in corruption deal and secretive
dealing,
those organizations that take an
exclusively proprietary mindset are
going to see themselves being left
behind and they're going to have to
adapt and evolve and take on a much more
collaborative and cooperative mountain
mindset to be able to keep up with the
economic growth.
That true open collaboration will bring.
And I think this is a really significant
trend.
You know,
there's many problems that we,
that we face as a global society.
No corruption,
for instance.
You know,
I don't think we've had corruption
probably since the first transaction,
uh,
and I don't think we're going to be able
to tackle that head on,
but we can potentially make corruption
obsolete by making it a relevant,
by making it,
um,
be an ineffective way to do business.
Okay.